- The other big issue is
the absolute murderous lie
that America remains
systemically racist.
We know that at one time it was,
but to continue
acting like it is
drives things like reparations,
race-based preferences,
diversity, equity, inclusion.
But more than that, it's
getting people killed.
It's called the George Floyd
Effect or the Ferguson Effect
and that's the phenomenon
of cops pulling back
from their normal
proactive policing
so that in the
last several years,
there are literally
thousands of people,
I call them excess
casualties, who are dead
or who have suffered
from violent crime,
who otherwise would
not have suffered
if the police had done their
normal proactive policing.
And the people, by the way, who
are these excess casualties,
are the very Black and brown
people that people on the left
purport to care about, which
is a common theme, by the way,
in my candidacy.
And then there's the absolute
disaster of urban education
in America where, just
to pick two cities,
Baltimore, 13 public high
schools, I kid you not,
where 0% of the kids can
do math at grade level.
Another half a
dozen, only 1% can.
Chicago, 53 government schools,
0% of the kids can do
math at grade level.
Nationwide, there's
something called
the America's Report Card.
I think it stands for
National Assessment
of Educational Policy,
the America's Report Card.
85% of Black eighth graders,
these are 13 year old kids,
can neither read nor
do math at grade level,
half can do basic reading.
But the Democratic Party,
because their largest
fundraiser funder
is the teacher's union,
adamantly opposed
the school choice
as the elites like
Barack Obama, Joe Biden,
Elizabeth Warren send their
own kids to private schools,
but they're denying
Black and brown kids
the opportunity to
do the same thing
even though polls show
in the inner city,
Black and brown parents
want school choice.
So if I can talk about
those issues and get them
front and center, Dave,
I will feel that I've
given back to my party.
And more importantly,
I will feel that I've
given back to my country.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the host of "The
Larry Elder Show",
former gubernatorial candidate
for the once great
state of California
and now candidate for
president of the United States
on the Republican side.
Going for that
nomination, we'll see.
My old friend Larry Elder,
welcome back to
"The Rubin Report".
- Dave, thank you so
much for having me.
I cannot tell you how many
people on the campaign trail,
typically young people tell
me that they discovered me
when you interviewed
me some years ago.
- Well, it goes both
ways, my friend,
because many people discovered
me when you beat me senseless
and all that stuff,
everyone knows about that.
Is there anything else you
wanna say about that moment
that you force fed
me the red pills?
Is there anything
that has not been said
about that at this point?
- I guess nothing
other than this, Dave.
You know, one of the
reasons I'm running
is because of the way we're
at each other's throats,
we meaning half the country
versus the other
half of the country.
My mother, I think you know
this, was a lifelong Democrat.
She was a regular
feature on my radio show
and my dad was a
lifelong Republican
and oh, to be a fly on the wall
when my mom and my dad were
arguing about politics.
But nobody ever called
anybody a fascist.
Nobody called anybody a Nazi.
Nobody said you only
care about the rich,
you don't care about the poor.
They argued civilly.
I have no idea why we've
gotten to the point now
we can't do that.
- Yeah and I come from a family
with a very similar
background in that regard.
It was all over the
place politically.
Argue it out and
dessert would be served
and everybody would put it down
and do it again the next night.
I wanna start today because
people do know our history.
Obviously, I know that you're on
the campaign trail right now.
I wanna start today with when
the recall did not work out
as you and I had hoped.
You and Nina came
over to my place,
I think the next night
or two nights after
and you said to me as I
cracked open a bottle of wine,
"Dave, I think I'm gonna run
for president of
the United States."
And I think I said,
"Larry, you crazy bastard."
And here we are,
you're doing it.
(Larry laughing)
- Well, and the reason
I'm doing it, Dave,
is because I am a
America first guy.
I'm a make America
great again guy.
I supported Donald Trump
in 2016 campaign for him
and with him, I supported
him again in 2020.
That's not the issue.
I'm bringing to the
table some things
I think the other side for
reasons that I cannot understand
are not talking about, our
side is not talking about.
Number one, the epidemic
of fatherlessness.
It is the 10,000 pound elephant
in the room that the left
doesn't want to talk about
because they caused it.
Our side doesn't wanna
talk about it for fear
I think that it's perceived
as denigrating single moms
who are often heroically
raising kids by themselves
or grandparents,
or they're afraid
of being called
systemically racist.
Or in my case, as you well
know, afraid of being called
the Black face of
white supremacy.
In 1965-
- Sorry, I didn't mention
that up top, you are the
Black face of white supremacy
according to "The LA Times".
- And I worked hard
to earn that title.
In 1965, Dave, 25% of Black
kids entered the world
without a father in the
home married to the mother.
Now it is 70%.
Today 25% of white kids
enter into the world
without a father in the
home married to the mother
and it's a consequence
of the welfare state
that Democrat Lyndon Johnson
launched in the mid '60s.
And since then, in my opinion,
what we've done is
to incentivize women
to marry the government
and incentivize men
to abandon their financial
and moral responsibility.
And these numbers I'm
about ready to cite
were also cited by Barack Obama
so you know they must be true.
A kid who's raised without a
dad is five times more likely
to be poor and commit crime,
nine times more likely
to drop outta school,
and 20 times more likely
to end up in jail.
I've got some ideas about
what we can do about that,
but no one's talking about it.
The other big issue is
the absolute murderous lie
that America remains
systemically racist.
We know that at one time it was,
but to continue acting
like it is drives things
like reparations,
race-based preferences,
diversity, equity, inclusion.
But more than that, it's
getting people killed.
It's called the George Floyd
Effect or the Ferguson Effect
and that's the phenomenon
of cops pulling back
from their normal
proactive policing
so that in the
last several years,
there are literally
thousands of people,
I call them excess
casualties, who are dead
or who have suffered
from violent crime,
who otherwise would
not have suffered
if the police had done their
normal proactive policing.
And the people, by the way, who
are these excess casualties,
are the very Black and brown
people that people on the left
purport to care about,
which is a common theme,
by the way, in my candidacy.
And then there's the absolute
disaster of urban education
in America where just to
pick two cities, Baltimore,
13 public high
schools, I kid you not,
where 0% of the kids can
do math at grade level.
Another half a dozen
where only 1% can.
Chicago, 53 government schools,
0% of the kids can do
math at grade level.
Nationwide, there's
something called
the America's Report Card,
I think it stands for
National Assessment
of Educational Policy,
the America's Report Card.
85% of Black eighth graders,
these are 13 year old kids,
can neither read nor
do math at grade level,
half can do basic reading.
But the Democratic Party,
because their largest
fundraiser funder
is the teacher's union,
adamantly opposes school choice
as the elites like
Barack Obama, Joe Biden,
Elizabeth Warren send their
own kids to private schools
but they're denying
Black and brown kids
the opportunity to
do the same thing,
even though polls show
in the inner city,
Black and brown parents
want school choice.
So if I can talk
about those issues
and get them front
and center, Dave,
I will feel that I've
given back to my party.
And more importantly,
I will feel that I've
given back to my country.
- Yeah, and it's
obvious from knowing you
on camera and off camera,
like how deeply you care
about these things.
These are real to you and the
things that you've been living
and talking about on the
radio for three decades
before doing it on the internet
now and everything else.
I wanna jump back to one
statistic you just mentioned
because when people
hear this idea,
I think you said,
if I'm not mistaken,
1964, 25% of Black children
were born in a one parent home,
so the mother, and now it's 70%.
Can you connect that
actually to Democrat policies
in a somewhat simple way
so people can really
understand that?
'Cause I think that
they hear the statistic
but they don't fully
understand well, okay,
how does that really
have something to do
with the welfare state?
So if we could connect that,
I think it would be great.
- If you look at the amount
of money that we spent
on the so-called war on
poverty from 1965 until now,
it's around $22 trillion.
If you look at the
trend line of kids
born outside of wedlock, it
parallels that trend line.
So in my opinion, there is
a connection, and again,
it was Lyndon
Johnson, a Democrat,
who launched a
so-called war on poverty
and his goal was to
provide a temporary basis
for people to escape poverty.
I don't believe he understood
that it was going to
create a dependency.
There was a poll in "The
LA Times" in the '80s
where people who were poor
and on welfare were asked,
do you believe that
welfare is a stepping stone
towards independence
or do you believe
that welfare is a crutch
that makes you dependent?
More called it a crutch, 41%,
than called it a stepping stone
towards independence, 31%.
There's an interesting
book called
"The Tragedy of
American Compassion"
by a guy named Marvin Olasky
and he looks at people
during the Great Depression
who were eligible for benefits,
for the New Deal benefits,
but for whatever reason,
reasons of pride,
self-sufficiency,
did not take them
and looked at those
families 20 years down
to find out which
ones were better.
And not too surprisingly,
the family that did not take
the welfare were far better off
than the family that
did take the welfare.
FDR even called
welfare, his New Deal,
which he thought was
gonna be temporary,
a quote, "Subtle
narcotic" close quote,
that trapped people
into dependency.
This is an age old problem.
Alexis de Tocqueville,
excuse me,
wrote about it in a book
called "Memoirs on Pauperism".
He was wealthy, was able
to travel around the world,
which was unusual in those days.
And he went to England,
which at the time was the
wealthiest country in the world.
And he saw that there were many,
many beggars on the streets
more than anywhere
else he had been.
He thought that was a conundrum.
It turned out that London,
England was the first state
to provide no questions
asked welfare.
And as a result, there
were far more people
who were dependent on welfare
than other states that
did not provide it.
It's just human nature.
Slovenly behavior if subsidized
becomes more slovenly.
You see that with homelessness,
you see that with
all sorts of things,
and you certainly see it with
people being incentivized
to have children without
a man being in the home.
- You know, I think I said this
when I helped campaign
with you, you know,
in some ways it's ironic
because I know you want to live
in a post-racial world,
in many ways we do,
and yet so much of
what you talk about
is addressing these
perceived racist issues
that there's a bit of a, I
suppose, a catch-22 in there.
Are you worried that
no matter how much
you lay out these ideas,
and clearly just from
our conversations,
the millions of people
who have been enlightened
by this stuff, you're affecting
a certain amount of people,
but that for whatever reason,
all time low Black unemployment
under Donald Trump,
you know, Black males,
I think it was 7%
that voted for Donald Trump,
and I think females were 4%,
that for whatever reason,
that thing has been so lodged
that it may be an intractable
problem politically?
- I don't think so.
In fact, the numbers are this.
Donald Trump got 8% of
the Black vote in 2016.
He got 12% in 2020,
a 50% increase,
but 20% of Black
males voted for him
and I believe for the
reason that you mentioned,
best economy ever for
blacks, he pardoned
the first Black heavyweight
champion, Jack Johnson.
He did the First
Step Act that allowed
some almost 5,000 mostly
Black men have their sentences
be considered to reduced an
average around 70 months.
He secured the borders.
The group most hurt
by illegal alien labor
are Black people living
in the inner city
because most of
the illegal aliens
have very little education,
so they compete against them.
One study done by the Civil
Rights Group found, Dave,
that about 1 million more
blacks would be working
if it weren't for the presence
of illegal alien labor
and illegal alien labor
puts downward pressure
to the tune of almost
$1,800 per year
on the salaries of people
living in the inner city.
And Donald Trump
supported school choice,
which as I mentioned, most
Black and brown parents
in the inner city want.
So I think if you lay out the
facts, lay out this fact too.
A young Black man, and I
consider this to be young
since I'm 71 years old, age 10
to 43 is 13 times more likely
to be murdered than a young
white man in the same demo.
Nationwide, 60% of the
homicides, the shootings,
and the robberies were
committed by blacks,
mostly young Black men.
Unless you're prepared to say
that blacks are just genetically
inclined to be criminals,
you have to ask yourself
what the devil is going on.
And I say that to people
who are upset with me
when I talk about
race being no longer
a major problem in America.
What's your analysis of why
Black people are doing this?
And the answer is the breakdown
of the nuclear intact family.
You do not find this
kind of criminality
when people come from
nuclear intact families.
There's a left wing publication
called "The Atlantic",
and a few months ago they had
this long, very
interesting article
about all the decisions
a young couple makes
when they have a kid, whether
from what to name him or her,
what color to paint the nursery.
The most important decision
is whether you're able to live
in a neighborhood
with a majority of
two parent households.
Even if you are a single parent
household, said the article,
you're gonna benefit by
being around families
that have two parents
in the household.
What does that tell you?
The most left wing popular
think tank in America
is the Brookings Institution.
They have a researcher
named Isabelle Sawhill,
S-A-W-H-I-L-L, done
a lot of research
on the importance of being
raised by two parent households
and laid out all the
stats we talked about
at the top of your show.
- Yeah, it's so interesting.
My parents still live in the
house that I was brought up in
that they bought in 1979.
They've been married over 50
years, I'm the oldest of three.
My mom stopped working
when I went to school,
so she made us, you
know, breakfast, lunch,
and dinner obviously,
was home when we came
home from school.
And then when my sister, who's
11 years younger than me,
when she was outta school,
my mom went back to work
and they have three, you know,
I'd like to think relatively
functioning children.
So basically what you're saying
is we all know it to be true,
but a whole bunch of
people are kind of afraid.
Let's talk a little bit, or
at least afraid to say it.
Let's talk a little bit
about what's going on
on the campaign,
because right now,
to get into the first debate,
you need 40,000
individual donors.
You don't quite have that
yet, you're on your way there,
and I hope that this show will
get some people to chip in
and we'll link to
that down below.
But you do qualify by
where you're polling at,
so you just need a few more
donors to get in there.
Can you just talk about
what your strategy has been
going out there,
talking to people?
I see you on the ground with
a lot of folks all the time,
taking questions, smiling,
kissing babies, all the stuff.
- (laughing) Well, my
strategy is to get on
as many programs like
yours to tell people
exactly what I need.
I've done a lot of Fox,
done a lot of Newsmax
and a lot of NewsNation.
I just did that
yesterday to tell people
I need 40,000 individual donors.
The amount can be as small as $1
and all you have to do is go
to my website, larryelder.com.
The criteria are at
least 1% in the polls
and 40,000 individual donors.
And frankly, I'm
kind of surprised
it's been that difficult to do.
I got 3.5 million votes
when I ran for governor.
On the replacement side,
California has 58
counties, I carried 57.
The only one I lost
was San Francisco,
and I lost that by 149 votes.
I raised more money
than all of the other
45 rival replacement
candidates combined,
more than all of the
Republicans combined.
Yet it's been very difficult,
I think because of the
presence of Trump and DeSantis,
and I think a lot of people
feel that they're likely
to be the nominee and
they don't want to quote,
"waste their money" close quote.
But as I said earlier, even
if you want somebody else,
at the very least, don't you
want me to be talking about
the issue of fatherlessness,
the lie that America
is systemically racist,
the need for school choice?
We also have on
our website, Dave,
a model legislation
that states can adopt
to set up commissions
of retired judges,
retired lawyers,
retired DAs rather,
to get rid of these soft on
crime George Soros backed DAs.
They're all over the place,
they're in San Francisco,
or at least they used to be
until the guy was recalled.
LA, been two attempts
to recall George Gascon.
In Philadelphia, there's
been an impeachment
of the George Soros backed DA,
but the Senate refused
to take up the trial.
They've got 'em in
Des Moines, Iowa.
Of course, they got
one in New York.
And this commission would allow
citizens to file complaints
and allow the commission
to hear the complaints
and if necessary to
recommend the removal
of that George Soros backed DA.
And finally, I'm arguing this.
We've had this standoff that
we have from time to time
on whether or not to
raise the debt ceiling.
And of course, you
and I both know
that the debt ceiling's
gonna be raised
because nobody wants to be
responsible for the consequences
of what happens if America
defaults on its debt.
And from time to time,
you have a standoff
on whether or not the
government ought to be shut down
and whenever it has
been, which it has been
a few times the last few years,
the party that is
perceived as blame worthy
gets hurt in the polls.
So I think going forward,
it's not likely we're gonna be
shutting down the government
either over funding.
The only way to
reign in spending,
because much of it
is on automatic pilot
because of the
so-called entitlements,
is with an amendment
to fix spending
to a certain
percentage of the GDP
with exceptions for war
and for natural disaster.
Otherwise, both parties
are gonna spend.
Government grew
under Ronald Reagan.
It grew under George
Herbert Walker Bush.
It grew under George W. Bush.
It grew under Donald Trump.
And woe to any politician
that runs promising
to reform social security
or reform Medicare
or reform Medicaid.
You will lose elections,
which is why the can is
always kicked down the road.
The word unsustainable
to describe
the so-called
entitlements was used
by Bill Clinton
and Barack Obama,
yet nothing gets done
because you'll be hammered,
you'll be killed,
you'll be massacred
in the polls if you do.
But if you are forced
to do so by law,
you can then come
out from the room
and say the devil made me do it,
please don't hurt me
at the ballot box.
- So I know the stuff
that's sort of your red meat
and the stuff that
you love talking about
and that you've been, you know,
hitting hard for
all these years.
When you're out there,
when you're in Iowa,
New Hampshire and some of
these early states now,
what's kind of the temperature
of the people on the right,
the Republicans, as
they're getting visits
from all of you guys now?
- The economy, the
economy, the economy.
People are concerned
about inflation,
they're concerned
about gas prices,
they're concerned about crime,
and they're concerned
about the borders.
I think those are
the primary issues
that people are concerned about
and people feel pushed around.
They feel that Donald
Trump has been subjected
to a two-tiered judicial system.
They're angry over Donald Trump
being indicted
over the documents,
but Joe Biden is still
being investigated.
I believe that OJ Simpson will
find the killer or killers
(Dave laughing)
of Ron and Nicole
before the Hunter
Biden investigation
has been completed.
And people are angry about
anybody that dares suggests,
that if you raise
questions about 2020,
you are an election denier,
even as Hillary for the entirety
of President Trump's term
referred to him as illegitimate,
said the election was stolen
with far less evidence.
I think people are
concerned about that,
but by and large people
are worried about
dinner table issues,
most notably the fact
that their wages are not
keeping up with inflation,
the high gas prices,
and overall the economy.
I think about 2/3 of
Americans, if not more,
believe that we're
on the wrong track.
- Yeah, what are people saying
about the Democrats right now?
Because I'd imagine everybody
sort of isn't into Biden,
but I'm guessing you're
probably also hearing
from some sort of
moderate Democrats
who are kind of thinking,
oh, maybe this is the year
to break away 'cause they're
so bananas right now.
- Well, you would hope so.
I think a lot of people,
Republicans I talk to,
feel Democrats are
just absolutely crazy.
They feel that they're
obsessed with things
like climate change.
They hear Joe Biden give a
speech at Howard University
and say the number one threat
to the homeland
is white supremacy
and they just wonder
who these people are.
You know, my mom, as
I mentioned, was a
lifelong Democrat,
but I got her to vote for
Republicans in latter years.
She voted twice
for George W. Bush
and she's one of those
democrats who believe
I didn't leave the
party, the party left me,
but she refused to change
her party registration
for, I think, emotional reasons.
- Let's jump back
to Cali for a sec,
because that is
where you still live.
You're still in Cali,
still in Los Angeles,
and I know you've got a good
life there and everything else.
I desperately tried to
get you to flee with me.
Do you think that
Cali, LA specifically,
but all these blue cities
that we're watching
sort of in the free fall,
do you think there is
a comeback for them
or do you think that they just
have not hit rock bottom yet
and there's just more to go?
- You know, I've written a
book about my California race
and what the one party
state has done to the state.
As you know, we've got super
majorities of Democrats
in the assembly
and in the Senate
so Republicans need not
even show up for work
and they pass one job
killing bill after another,
one freedom sapping
bill after another.
It's called "As Goes California,
My Mission to Rescue the Golden
State and Save the Nation".
My goals are modest and, again,
I liken it to a drug addict.
At some point, you would think
the voters would hit rock bottom
and begin to rethink
their assumptions
and put different people in
office but it's not happening.
You know, the recall part lost
by a pretty substantial margin.
A guy named Caruso ran
against Karen Bass,
the Black female Democrat
who was elected mayor of LA.
He outspent her 10 to
one, lifelong developer,
had great ideas about what
to do about the homeless,
and he got crushed and I
thought maybe there might be
a chance given the crime in LA,
given the homelessness in LA,
given the fact that
the average price
of a home in California is 175%
above the national average,
the poor schools, I
thought maybe just maybe
there would be a
chance that the voters
would find somebody that
they could get around.
I saw the debates,
very competent debater.
He got crushed, so
I really don't know.
I don't think we're there yet.
You know, I thought
maybe when the crime
went to the suburbs, maybe
something would happen.
A few years ago, a retired
Motown mogul in his 80s
married to a woman in her
80s, lives in Beverly Hills,
has armed security
at his house, Dave.
Guy broke in who never should
have been on the streets
and shot and killed the woman.
Then shortly after that,
a UCLA graduate student
working in a store
in Hancock Park,
the very tony area of
LA where Maxine Waters
has her $5 million mansion.
- It's not her district,
but that's where
she has her mansion.
- Well, it used to
be her district,
and now the district changed
and the rules are you
can keep your house
where you used to have it
so technically she
hasn't violated any law.
But anyway, UCLA
graduate student
was working at a
furniture store.
A guy comes in, homeless guy,
shouldn't have been
on the streets,
with a knife kills her
and I would've thought
that maybe just maybe when
the crime comes to the burbs,
something would happen
with these elites
that are sending all this money
to people like Gavin Newsom.
But it still hasn't
happened, so at some point,
according to my former
nextdoor neighbor, Mrs. Cluss,
things don't always keep
getting bad forever.
So at some point, the lust
factor's gotta kick in,
but I don't know
when that's gonna be.
- We only have a
couple minutes left.
Let's just talk a little
bit about the ins and outs
of what's going on
with the Republicans
'cause you mentioned
the big two, obviously,
it's Trump and DeSantis.
As you're watching them kind
of go at each other, you know,
you can sort of
somewhat sit it out,
but what do you make of
the brewing war there?
It's a damn shame, I mean,
you know where I'm at kinda
and how I fled so
publicly to Florida,
but I did support
Trump, I love you.
Like, you know, I want
you on that debate stage
and all this stuff,
but what do you make
of just like the war
that's brewing right now?
Is this just politics and
we all gotta get past it?
- Well, we should
understand that the target
is the Harris Biden
administration.
Notice I said Harris Biden,
because if Joe cannot
fog up a mirror,
it's gonna be Kamala Harris
and after he gets
across the finish line,
he's gonna hand over
the baton to her,
so that's what the target is.
And during the recall
campaign, you might recall,
I never said a
single negative thing
about my Republican rivals.
Unfortunately, they did not
abide by the same tenant.
Had they done so, had they
done what I always did
when I was given a chance
to take a shot at John Cox
or Kevin Faulconer, that's a
two term mayor of San Diego
that the establishment party
wanted in California to win.
By the way, I took
San Diego County
by 30 points, just saying.
When I had a chance to take
a shot at Caitlyn Jenner,
I always said,
they're not the issue,
the issue is Gavin Newsom.
Ask Gavin Newsom at
what point does he feel
a pregnancy has gone so far
that it constitutes homicide?
Ask Gavin Newsom
why he hasn't put
his own kids in public school.
Ask Gavin Newsom why
he was yucking it up
at the French Laundry
with the people
that drafted the mandates
not wearing a mask,
not engaging in
social distancing.
Same thing here, the
target is the inflation,
the target is the crazy borders.
We're gonna have about
8 million illegal aliens
in the country by the
end of his first term,
Lord knows how many more by
the end of his second term.
The war on oil and gas has
caused our gas prices to go up.
All the spending, the
illegal debt forgiveness,
and the denigration
of police officers.
He's the target and so any
one of these candidates
would be superior to the
Harris Biden administration.
We have a really deep bench
and we ought to be
proud of that and I am.
- You know, hearing you
talk about how you behaved
and the way you did not
attack the other guys
on your side of the aisle
during that campaign,
it reminds me that two or
three days before the recall
that, what was his name?
Reed Hastings from Netflix
was pouring millions
and millions of dollars,
in essence calling you a white
supremacist and, you know,
you're Trump, evil,
blah, blah, blah.
And then they sent
Biden and Obama to Cali
to campaign for Gavin
and they refused to
even say your name.
You remember that?
- Right, oh yeah,
and Joe Biden said,
well, Joe Biden said my name.
- Oh, he did?
- He said, "Larry Elder
is the closest thing to a Donald
Trump that I've ever seen."
- Oh, so it was Obama that
wouldn't say your name, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, it was Joe Biden.
"Larry Elder is the closest
thing to a Trump clone
that I've ever seen."
Should I be flattered (laughing)
or should I be offended?
- Larry, remind
people for a moment.
Donald Trump came from his dad
worth obviously like
hundreds of millions.
Your dad was a janitor,
if I'm not mistaken,
probably not worth
hundreds of millions.
- My dad never knew
his biological father,
was kicked outta the house
by his irresponsible mom
when he was 13 years old.
Athens, Georgia, Jim Crow South
at the beginning of
the Great Depression.
He ended up, when I was
growing up, cleaning toilets,
two full-time jobs
cleaning toilets,
cooked for his
family on the weekend
because he wanted my mom
to be a stay-at-home mom.
Went to night school
to get his GED,
then went to night school
to learn how to operate
a small restaurant,
started a small restaurant
in his late 40s, ran
it until his 80s.
When my dad retired, he
owned the restaurant,
he owned a little bit
of property next door
plus the home that's
still in our family,
not too shabby for
somebody who really faced
brutal racism when
he was growing up.
That's why I have
so little tolerance
for the way Democrats are
trying to tell Black people
that they remain oppressed.
It is nonsense.
The formula to escape poverty
is pretty straightforward.
Finish high school, don't have
a kid until you get married.
Get married first, get a job.
Keep that job, don't quit that
job till you get another job
and avoid the criminal
justice system.
Do that, you will not be poor.
And that is what Democrats
ought to be telling
young Black people, instead
they're telling them
people owe you something,
people owe you reparations.
Which in my opinion is
the extraction of money
from people who were
never slave owners
to be given to people
who were never slaves.
The Democratic party has pimped
Black people for decades.
They need that nearly 90,
95% monolithic Black vote
without which they
cannot win at the top
and so rather than get
Black people talking about
bad schools and crime and jobs,
they got 'em talking about
social justice, excuse me,
and equity, whatever the
devil those things mean.
- Larry, you are a
colleague, a mentor,
and most importantly, a friend.
I'm honored to have been
on this journey with you
and let's get you
to those 40,000.
So the link is right down below,
and I wish you luck my friend.
- We've got country to save.
Thanks, Dave, as always.
I appreciate it, God bless.
(gentle music)
- If you're looking
for more honest and
thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.